it's quite remarkable that in a short 48
hours this entire Nicki Minaj swollen
testicle uh Trinidad and Tobago story
has gone from something I didn't think I
would cover at all to something I ended
up covering yesterday because of how it
suddenly pulled in Fox News propaganda
Tucker Carlson to something that today
we're following up on and it has
actually reached the health Ministry of
Trinidad and Tobago so let's just go
through the entire backstory on this uh
the way that this all started is that uh
pop star Nicki Minaj tweeted a couple of
days ago quote my cousin in Trinidad
won't get the vaccine because his friend
got it and became impotent his testicle
testicles became swollen his friend was
weeks away from getting married now the
girl called off the wedding
it's kind of weird it'd be like why
that's like if someone gets appendicitis
do you call off the wedding uh so just
pray on it and make sure you're
comfortable with your decision and not
bullied and of course so many people
came forward and said that's not
actually a vaccine side effect just
because something happened after the
vaccine if it did doesn't mean it was
caused by the vaccine uh my instinct was
maybe maybe the testicular swelling is
an STD from an affair and that's why the
wedding was canceled I even tweeted much
to the Delight of many in my audience
back to Nikki Nikki is it maybe possible
the swollen Apple bags were an STD from
cheating and that's why the wedding was
called off Tucker Carlson then got
subsequently involved and said we want
to interview this individual we want to
talk to this individual
who um supposedly had these swollen
testicles this has now gone all the way
up to the health minister of Trinidad
and Tobago who explains we had to wait a
little bit before responding because we
needed to see what was this reported the
population is low enough there that this
would be something they would have a
record of uh he says there is no such
reported case let's take a listen one of
the reasons we could not respond
yesterday in real time to miss Minaj
is that we had to check and make sure
that what she was claiming was either
true or false
we did this and unfortunately we wasted
so much time yesterday running down this
false claim this guy is disgusted which
I love he should be
it is as far as we know at this point in
time
there has been no such reported either
side effect or adverse event
and what was sad about this
is that
it wasted our time yesterday
trying to track down because we take all
these claims seriously right whether
it's on social media or mainstream media
as we stand now
there is absolutely no reported
such side effect or adverse event of
testiculus valid in Trinidad or ideac Dr
Heinz anywhere else
none that we know of anywhere else in
the world okay so of course if you're
committed to this story you would say
well a lot of people don't report their
side effects uh I had arm pain or I had
a headache I never reported it
um and of course if you want to be
endlessly skeptical you can you can
continue to be but that is the statement
from the health minister in Trinidad and
Tobago so what's the real takeaway here
the takeaway here is that we're working
so hard to get people vaccinated and to
disseminate truth and empiricism and and
to make sure that what's being said is
backed up by data and Science and
someone like Nicki Minaj who's in a
position with so much prominence nearly
200 million followers across social
media Etc
with just one tweet could theoretically
dissuade I don't know if I want to say
tens of thousands like of the 200
million followers how many are currently
unvaccinated who have access Etc right
maybe she's dissuading tens of thousands
of people from vaccination maybe
hundreds of thousands is it possible
that it's in the millions I don't know
but it can then take weeks to undo the
skepticism that's caused by just one
statement like that and that's why this
is so disturbing
um if this individual eventually comes
forward
Tucker Carlson goes down to Port of
Spain and interviews the guy the way he
said he wanted to do okay we'll follow
up on it but let's hope that this is the
end of the Nicki Minaj swollen testicle
story
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies I've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews and best of all if you
don't love it you'll get 100 of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try four sigmatic is
giving my audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic.com com slash Pacman the link
is right underneath this video